اليوم مباراه مصريه مع المنتخب الاسباني
توقعك للمباراه اليوم يا مباريات الجيران
ان شاء الله هتكون مباراه حارقه مكسيكيه
محضه ان شاء الله نتفوقوا في وسط الميدان
عندنا مرابط عندنا مناحي عندنا لعابه اللي
قادرين انهم يفوزوا
الثنائيات الملعب ثلاثه واحد ان شاء الله
بالمرتدات عليهم
في الدوري الاسباني عندهم التجربه عندهم
خبره يعرف
الاسبانيه يلعب تاكسي كاتهم طرق اللعب
عارفينهم حافظينهم واسبانيا اسود مع
المغرب
كبيره ان شاء الله سنفوز توقعات اثنان
للسفر احنا اسود الاطلس
همم المباراه ان شاء الله وقت يكون صعب ان
شاء الله احنا طامحين ان شاء الله والفوز
ان شاء الله مره نفوز ان شاء الله
كم النتيجه
قادر المغرب
الحب وطنا
بلجيكا
وانتصرنا قدام كندا ان شاء الله
الخير علينا ونغلبوا ثلاثه واحد
[موسيقى]